1996 年
日本將棋的七大頭銜被同一個人全部拿走
史上第一次
他叫羽生善治，15 歲當上職業棋士
下了 40 年
去年累計到 1600 勝
將棋就是日本的象棋
也是最早被 AI 追過去的領域之一
今年 9 月公開的這段訪談裡
他講了一件跟多數人想的相反的事
AI 越強，棋士眼前的路越看不清楚
節目是 NewsPicks 的 WEEKLY OCHIAI
主持人是媒體藝術家落合陽一
跟 AI 下棋，有什麼是人身上沒有的有趣地方？
那種我想 100 年也絕對想不到的棋
它若無其事地就下出來了
它的點子怎麼來的，想法的範圍怎麼拉寬
這些都很值得參考
真好
不過，該怎麼說呢
「這一手看了不舒服，不想下」
這種棋很多
將棋碰上 AI 的時間
比大多數行業都早
2017 年
AI 在正式對局贏了當時拿著名人頭銜的棋士
之後職業棋士反過來拿 AI 當研究工具
落合陽一自己做生成式 AI 的研究
他把將棋當成走在前面的例子來問
電腦越來越厲害
將棋以外的領域大概也是，像數學家現在也在用 AI
幾乎每一個領域，都很猛烈地
開始發生將棋界已經發生過的事
比計算能力，人大概已經贏不了 AI
但跟它一起做，能做出更有創意的東西
羽生先生看到這些，會怎麼想
會不會覺得「這條路我們這一行早就走過了」
啊，原來如此
當然，從 AI 的歷史來看
棋盤遊戲本來就是比較容易做出成果的領域
類似的現象，現在也擴散到別的領域
我想是有的
不過，該怎麼說呢
拿到現實世界去用，跟在網路空間裡
在電腦裡就能做完的那種世界
基本上是兩回事
所以會發生的現象跟反應，我想不太一樣
您上次來的時候
我做生成式 AI 的研究做很久了
2022 年，我的程式還有一半是自己動手寫的
原來如此
現在是一行程式
都不自己動手寫了
拿將棋來比喻的話很有意思
大概就是自己動手下，精準度反而會變鈍
所以乾脆不自己動手，變成這種狀態
我自己都覺得很不可思議
不過反過來說，就算完全不自己動手
要選什麼，終究是人在做的事
至於哪裡有價值
哪裡有可能性
AI 不會連這些都幫你想
所以反過來說，就是要自己去選
要做哪個領域，力氣花在哪裡去分析、去研究
我想這個很重要
您說得對
這也是我自己的研究主題
人類一直把「做出東西」當成一種價值
把「做」交給別人之後，「選」就變得非常重要
因為做出來的東西會多到滿出來
要抓哪個關鍵，力氣往哪裡放
反而是「選」這件事變重要
我也這麼想
將棋的世界也一樣
有很多像死巷一樣的領域
一走進死巷，花掉大把時間
結果什麼都生不出來
要查當然可以一直查下去
技術上也做得到了
可是怎麼避開那些死巷
是現在很重要的課題
我覺得重點就在這裡
能不能選到不走進死巷的路
就是您剛才講的那件事
對
舉個很好懂的例子
不是有圓周率的計算嗎
圓周率幾乎可以永遠算下去
將棋裡也有這種局面
一開始查下去，就只是在浪費時間
「這個大概沒完沒了」「這個不會有結論」
「現在做也沒意義」，要看得出來然後放手
把力氣集中在關心的題目、該做的事情上
我想這會變得很重要
對局當中也一樣嗎？往這邊算下去
會走進死巷，所以這裡先不想了
把腦力挪到另一邊去，您會這樣判斷嗎？
是啊
AI 越進步，越是在沒有明確結論、沒有答案的情況下
還是得往前走，這種情況越來越多
最近嗎？
越到最近越多
不是很有把握地覺得「這邊比較好」
而是一直帶著一種模糊
沒有把握就往前走，這種情況多了非常多
反而很難有「下對了」的手感
這是最近將棋界的特色
有意思。就是棋盤上聞到的味道不一樣了
對
以前多少可以先弄清楚再往前走
現在一直是暗中摸索，在五里霧中
往前走，這種情況非常多
原來如此
這大概是因為，大家跟 AI 一起激盪
開發出沒見過的棋
那些新棋，是往結局看不清楚的地方衝進去的
大家卻意外地都在用、都在研究
說到底，尤其是將棋
職業棋士對上職業棋士，多半在沒見過的局面碰頭
從那裡往下，不管怎麼走都是未知的世界
然後還會變得更複雜
一路都是搞不清楚狀況的發展
社會上一般的印象
是有了 AI，什麼問題都能解決，一切變得清清楚楚
大家很容易這樣想
我覺得並不是
反而是模糊的、不明確的地方
會一直一直冒出來
至於能不能自在地
接受這件事，那又是另一回事了
落合接著說，商業世界也一樣
AI 一出現就把局面攪亂
兩年後會怎樣幾乎沒人說得準
大家只確定電力跟半導體很重要
將棋開始常常讓人覺得霧濛濛的
大概是哪一年的事？
大概是這 5 年左右吧
所以差不多是疫情那時候？
從那時候起，我覺得變了很多
將棋的 AI 化，比外面早了 7 到 9 年
這樣算，我們闖進同一種狀態的時間
現在又在加速，開個根號來算
大概 2029 年，就真的是霧濛濛的世界了
感覺現在就已經開始起霧了
已經開始了，對吧
我自己也是很切身地感覺到
在這種霧裡，大概要很會抓直覺的人
才有辦法做得好
這一點我感受很深
是啊
不過，正因為這樣
我想差距很容易被拉開
量不出來、也驗證不了的事情
正在發生的時候
就是最容易拉開巨大差距的時候
不過我在大學教學生
碰到這種霧濛濛的局面，很多孩子會提不起勁
是啊，我想也是
不知道該怎麼辦
腳就是跨不出去，這種孩子很多
看到這樣卡住不動的孩子
換成將棋，您會跟他說什麼，讓他突破？
嗯，像是「去旅行走一走」之類的
去旅行啊
得把它當成日常，當成本來就是這樣
不然我想是很難撐下去的
可是全人類，不對，是棋士一直在練這個
一直都在做
所以再霧的局面，也會去想怎麼往前走
一般人是受完義務教育、進了大學
在霧最濃的時候找工作，這種學生我常接觸
他們是真的會開始煩惱
這種事，我覺得不要每個人都去做
這樣才比較健康
喜歡這種事的人、興趣特別強的人
好奇心特別旺盛的人
只讓這些人去做，我覺得健康得多
要是每個人都這樣，大家的壓力只會越來越大
落合沒有放過這一題
他說現實是整個世界都已經起霧
不喜歡這種局面的人
處境只會越來越糟
羽生說現在是過渡期
然後把話接回他前面講過的那個字
所以說到最後
剛才講過「選」這件事
我覺得，選擇本身就是個性
當然，從零生出東西的那種創意上的個性
我想還是會留下來
但一直選下去的結果
會變成那個人的風格，那個人獨有的東西
我是這樣想的
AI 下得出人想 100 年也想不到的棋
棋士眼前的路反而更霧
在霧裡每一步選了什麼，羽生善治說
那就是一個人的個性
原影片 20 分鐘
前半段他講了當將棋連盟會長的那兩年
舊會館有兩個入口
下棋的日子他走左邊
處理會務的日子走右邊
靠這個切換腦袋
他也講了怎麼看一個小孩會不會變強
看的是他分不分得出哪裡該想
哪裡想了也沒用
原影片連結在說明欄，有興趣可以去聽更多。